congratulations to both of you for your
performance in this my first question is
looking at that art piece what is a
reflect for you I mean there's a lot of
symbolism in it yeah with the bird being
chained to its post and when you look
look at it and the Goldfinch is looking
on to everybody for helping and looking
on for everybody to kind of yeah and it
reflects Theo and his being chained to
the event that happened to him and him
being chained to these memories of his
mother and to Pippa and ultimately not
looking for attention and seeking for
attention is something I think Theo both
wants and also does not one yeah it's
interesting how you know it says 1654
mm-hmm and that's a guy that we don't
know mm-hmm but it still had so much
significance and art can really last
forever you really can I wonder also in
the digital age if you know one day when
we move on from this planet we'll still
have all this art that represents Earth
and we'll have it digitally because
we'll probably lose it all when we when
we end up in nuclear warfare is
meaningful that is it's still meaningful
all because we're not looking at the
real painting we're looking at a print
out of it so we could print it again
later anyway yeah and it's even at
looking at a print out that's the wrong
scale and it's pixelated in a weird way
it still holds your attention you still
want to look at it for a long time and
and I have to tell you Ansel um
I've never seen you in a character like
this before it was dark whoa your nails
are cool that's my car
you're like oh wow Chrome number 10 but
you are dark in this film you took it to
a place I didn't expect you to take it
and dealing with the drug addiction and
you lost a lot of weight for it as well
I'm assuming it really tapped into you
mentally and it must have been very
difficult for you to get to that point
even as an actor yeah I mean nothing is
worthwhile unless it's difficult that's
it yeah yeah things are hard when
hopefully it yeah I felt good and yeah
good to do it in yeah I I only wish that
I could do it again
really I don't know you said that I'd be
cool to do it again yeah just like
reading the book again I'm reading it
again now are you all 900 pages
771 oh look at that and how are you
still making music I understand that
you're working on an album right now
yeah we doesn't make music yeah it's
nice cuz uh I just get to it's like any
art form thing with movies sometimes it
can be like you're very much a part of a
big puzzle which is great I mean what an
amazing puzzle to be part of but yeah
it's nice to be just like just to feel
like you can just throw paint around
working it out yeah what is the most
important possession that you have in
your life I don't want to reduce my dog
to possession he dies yeah really does
my dog Mickey is the one thing that I
was saved from a fire well maybe a
couple other things but he's the one
that I would I would go to he's the one
I can grab what I'm feeling
that's all side and down or whatever ya
[Laughter]
know a lot of stuff in here
your first breather my birds I got this
hat ah see that very nice I love
this was from the what's that story set
yeah um I got some my jewelry with me
you actually wear those how were these
yeah not right now it's not really in
the vibe for this oppressed or but very
nice you like organs to I understand
have some rings II hmm I got I just
bought this this choker
yes usually I did my answer did this and
you got a you gotta bring your passport
reviews
I forgot it this morning but I remember
thankfully yeah my goldfish thank you
guys I will see you during award season
right on the record yeah